>>Jonathan Winn: You ready?
>>Student: Yes.
[drum playing]
[students clapping]
>>Everybody: Jets!
>>Jonathan Winn: Was
that our best one?
>>Everybody: Yes!
>>Jonathan Winn: Really?
Okay, I thought it
was pretty good.
Seven easy steps.
Step by step goes
the marching band.
Dang it, I keep putting
that down.
>>Student: Here.
>>Jonathan Winn: Here.
Step one, you already know it.
>>Everybody: Write
what you know.
>>Jonathan Winn:
Write what you know.
The student body
definitely is low income.
Ninety five percent of
the students here qualify
for free or reduced lunch.
They represent what the
world is really like,
the diversity of the world.
Not only the world, but
the future of the world.
The world is mixing together.
>>Carl Munn: What do we
do with the variable?
>>Students: [inaudible]
>>Carl Munn: So is this
gonna be x squared?
>>Everybody: No.
>>Carl Munn: No.
>>Jonathan Winn: I got involved
in this school a few years ago
because I noticed some
really powerful instruction
that was happening
in the algebra class.
>>Carl Munn: This
is where students,
they either get this stuff
right now and they get confident
with it, or they
don't really spend--
take the time to get
really good at this,
and then they don't like math.
They get frustrated.
They stop coming to school.
>>Jonathan Winn: Yeah,
I basically copied
everything Mr. Munn does
from his curriculum planning
to his instructional strategies
and infuse some of my own
things and took some things
from a number of other great
teachers that I had encountered
and observed, and
I'm just using them.
They're just things that work.
>>Carl Munn: We're gonna
spend a lotta time with this
and make sure that everyone
really gets this before you...
>>You know, what used to happen
here was my kids would get a
pretty experience in my
class and then they'd move
on to the next coupla
classes and it just--
it was like they just went
right back off the cliff.
>>Perfect, perfect, perfect.
>>And having John here now, it's
like I know, once they're done
in this room, you know,
they're going to end
up in his intermediate
and pre cal class.
And we have this now
Capstone calculus course
which is just generating
so much excitement,
and it's the most popular class.
>>Jonathan Winn: It's
a big old fraction.
Okay, so you're gonna
start with a quotient--
>>What you see up here on
the stage is just a mix
of techniques, all
proven techniques.
>>How's that one go?
>>Everybody: [inaudible].
>>Jonathan Winn: No, no, no, no.
>>I want them yelling things
out loud and I wanna go outside
and hear it, so that other
people on campus can hear it,
just get it shaken
up a little bit.
>>How's that one go
>>Everybody: [inaudible].
>>Jonathan Winn: Thank you.
>>When it comes to specific
techniques to meet the needs
of let's say English learners,
there's some specific
things that, you know,
color coordination,
that type of thing.
>>First is F. Oh, wrong color.
F doesn't change.
>>There's this girl, Sokna
and she said to me 'Mr. Winn,
I don't understand anything
you're saying in class,
but I watch what's
going on on the board,
and that's how I learn it.'
And she's a top student.
>>So now we know what it is.
Now let's make sure
we can use it.
>>Sokna: Mr. Winn, he is easy
for me to understand what he try
to tell, but actually, I didn't
really pay attention to him,
but I just look at how
he did on the problem
and then I just copy it and then
I try to do it and I get right.
>>Jonathan Winn: It's kind of
like a little calculus jingle,
low di high minus high
di low, all over low low.
>>The stuff that we do in
here, whether it's a skit,
whether it's a marching
band problem,
whether it's some kinda
interactive thing or hands
on thing, it may or
may not help that much
with understanding the topic,
but I think it makes class fun.
>>Woman: Gottfried.
Gottfried Wilhelm Leibniz,
where are you, son?
>>Jonathan Winn: All over H.
>>I saw this little
thing about Leibniz
in 1675 on vacation in Paris.
I thought it was hilarious that
he was doing calculus in Paris,
on vacation, which is, strangely
enough, I've done that plenty
of times on vacation,
doing calculus.
And so I called Becky
up, say, 'You got a wig?
You got a puffy shirt?
Let's do this.'
>>Woman: You, ever since your
father died when you were six,
you doing the things with
the numbers all the time
on the pieces of paper.
>>Jonathan Winn: Oh
mother, be quiet.
>>Woman: Oh, please, please--
>>Jonathan Winn: For a
student to come to a class
and to always feel
like something
like that could happen.
I feel like that's
the type of thing
that may encourage a
student to sort of be
on the edge of their seat.
And that's how I want them.
I want them, the second
they walk in, ready to go.
On the edge of their
seat the whole time.
Bell rings, that's
when you stop working.
>>When a group of people,
100 people out there, you,
are all doing something, it
doesn't even matter what,
but if we're doing
it at the same time,
like reading off low di high
minus high di low over low, low,
saying that together is a way
to practice our strengths.
>>Erica: My definition
of a teacher is just,
teaching the lesson
and making sure
that your students understand
the materials that are taught.
But sometime he stayed here with
us until seven or eight o'clock
at night, doing math, and I
think that's an amazing thing.
[drum playing] [students
clapping]
>>Everybody: Crawford!
>>Jonathan Winn: Nice.
>>In a lotta ways, I use the
ocean as kinda like a way
to like just wash off
the day, you know,
like wash off the costume.
I take off my tie.
You know, I'm taking
off the hat.
Mr. Winn hat is being
hung up for the day.
Put that costume
in the closet and,
you know, it's back to John.
And so for me, it's
really important
to have some little ritual
that gets performed at the end
of every professional day.
Being out in the water tends to
be a really important experience
for me on a regular basis.
Being on the edge of that wave,
being on the edge of, you know,
potentially falling off
and getting crunched--
and I've been out there where
I've taken a bad fall and being
in a really tough situation,
underwater and having
to basically figure it out in
that moment, and almost like a--
kind of like a life
or death situation.
And I don't think calculus is
life or death for the students,
but I do think that
when you're faced
with a really tough problem,
you either have the skills
and the capacity to
rise up, or you don't.
And I believe that the
key is self belief.
>>What do we know?
[cross talk]
>>Jonathan Winn: Okay, we
know a whole bunch of stuff.
We'd better do them
one at a time.
Just put up a hand.
Right there, what's
something you know?
>> For me, it's really
important to have consistency,
and really setting the tone
that instructional minutes are
valuable, and we're not going
to waste a single one.
This is serious business.
And they're getting
that homework done
and they're working
hard in class
and they're asking questions.
Why? Because this
is serious business,
and it makes the
teaching day wonderful.
>>Finish solving this
system with substitution
and take a look up
here at what I have
and make sure you
have the same thing.
Go. [bell rings]